SEAN.
>> Sean: THANKS FOR THAT REPORT
TONIGHT.
UNBELIEVABLE.
ALSO REMEMBER AS DEMOCRATS FUEL
EVEN MORE BASELESS TIN FOIL
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, THIS TIME
A COVER-UP BY ATTORNEY GENERAL
BARR.
LOOK AT THIS LAW.
THE OBSTRUCTION LAW.
18USE, 1505.
LOOK AT THE LANGUAGE.
IT REQUIRES INTENT AND ANY
OBSTRUCTION CASE HINGES ON
WHETHER SOMEONE WAS CORRUPTLY
TRYING TO INFLUENCE THE
INVESTIGATION.
I THINK THAT'S LIKE IF YOU HAVE
SUBPOENAED EMAILS THE INTENT TO
DELETE THEM, CLEAN OUT YOUR
HARD DRIVE WITH BLEACH BIT.
BUST UP YOUR DEVICES WITH
HAMMERS AND TAKE OUT SIM CARDS
MIGHT SHOW INTENT.
THE ATTORNEY FOR THE PRESIDENT,
FORMER MAYOR OF NEW YORK CITY
RUDY GIULIANI.
MR. MAYOR, NINE-MONTH F.B.I.
THEY CONCLUDED NO THERE THERE.
WE HAD HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE NO
COLLUSION.
BIPARTISAN SENATE COMMITTEE NO
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR QUOTED
ROBERT MUELLER, NO COLLUSION.
NOW THEY'VE MOVED ON TO THIS.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE LAW THAT I
JUST MENTIONED.
>> IT'S DISGRACEFUL, SEAN.
THE REALITY IS THAT TO OBSTRUCT
JUSTICE YOU HAVE TO THREATEN,
IMPEDE, YOU HAVE TO GET IN THE
WAY OF SOMEBODY.
LET'S GO BACK TO THE ONE THAT
WEINSTEIN AND ALL OF HIS ANGRY
DEMOCRATS USED TO PUSH.
WHICH IS WHEN THE PRESIDENT
ALLEGEDLY SAID.
THE PRESIDENT SAID THIS
CONVERSATION NEVER TOOK PLACE.
HE SAID TO FLYNN, YOU KNOW, I
HOPE YOU CAN SEE FIT TO DROP
THIS OR NOT PURSUE THIS.
FIRST OF ALL, YOU DON'T HAVE
OBSTRUCTION BY HOPE.
YOU HAVE OBSTRUCTION BY
COERCION, THREAT, I'LL BREAK
YOUR LEGS, I'LL TAKE YOUR FOOD
AWAY OR I'LL KIDNAP YOUR
CHILDREN.
I PROSECUTED A LOT OF
OBSTRUCTION CASES.
NOBODY STARTED AN OBSTRUCTION
SENTENCE WITH I HOPE.
NOBODY HAD OBSTRUCTION BY
PUTTING OUT A LEGAL MEMO FOR
THE WHOLE WORLD TO SEE.
WE'LL FIND OUT IN A WEEK OR TWO
HOW ACCURATE BILL BARR'S
SUMMARY WAS.
I'LL TELL YOU, IT WILL BE 100%
ACCURATE.
BILL BARR IS A GREAT LAWYER AND
HE IS A VERY HONORABLE MAN.
I CAN'T SAY THAT FOR THE
CONGRESSMEN MAKING ALL THESE
WILD, CRAZY, INSANE THREATS.
THEIR CLAIM OF OBSTRUCTION
AGAINST THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF
THE UNITED STATES IS NO BETTER
THAN A TWO YEAR CLAIM OF
OBSTRUCTION BY THE ANGRY
DEMOCRATS THAT TRIED TO CLAIM
THE PRESIDENT WAS OBSTRUCTED.
HE DIDN'T OBSTRUCT ANYTHING.
THE BEST EVIDENCE IS THEY
COMPLETED THEIR DARN
INVESTIGATION.
HOW DID IT GET OBSTRUCTED?
NOTHING WAS.
>> Sean: IT WAS VERY CLEAR IN
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S LETTER
THAT BOTH HE AND ROD
ROSENSTEIN, WHO APPOINTED THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL DECIDED QUICKLY
WITHOUT ANY CONSIDERATION OF
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT RULE
ABOUT WHETHER OR WHETHER OR NOT
YOU CAN INDICT A SITTING
PRESIDENT, MORE IMPORTANTLY IT
WAS BEING DISCUSSED THE WHOLE
TIME AND THERE IS ALSO BEYOND
INTENT THERE IS NO CRIME.
SO THE PRESIDENT IS SAYING I
HOPE FLYNN DOESN'T GO TO JAIL
AFTER SERVING HIS COUNTRY OR
FIRING COMEY WHICH HE HAD A
RIGHT TO DO OR SAYING IT'S A
WITCH HUNT.
NOBODY WAS OBSTRUCTED.
>> THIS WOULD BE A OBSTRUCTION
CASE TO END ALL OBSTRUCTION
CASES.
SOMEBODY OBSTRUCTED TO OBSTRUCT
AN INVESTIGATION OF A NON-CRIME.
THAT HE WAS INNOCENT OF AND
THEN IT TURNED OUT HE DIDN'T
OBSTRUCT.
THAT THEY INTERVIEWED 500
WITNESSES, GOT 1.4 MILLION
DOCUMENTS, GOT EVERY WISHFUL
FILLED AND ENGAGED IN SOME
PRACTICES THAT ARE TRULY
HORRENDOUS LIKE RAIDS IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT, BRINGING
CNN IN TO PHOTOGRAPH RAIDING
STONE'S HOUSE FOR EXAMPLE.
LEAKING NOW.
EVERYBODY MISSES THE REAL POINT
HERE.
THE REAL WRONGDOING ARE THE
PROSECUTORS WHO JUST LEAKED.
I THOUGHT MUELLER DIDN'T LEAK.
HUH.
YOU BELIEVE THAT ONE AND I'LL
SELL YOU THE BROOKLYN BRIDGE.
>> Sean: LET ME CHANGE TOPICS.
A FEW DAYS THERE IS AN ELECTION
IN ISRAEL.
WE'RE FRIENDS WITH NETANYAHU.
YOU HAVE THIS CRAZY OPPONENT
WHO ACTUALLY IS PUSHING -- HE
IS SAYING TO THE PEOPLE OF
ISRAEL.
PUTIN IS TRYING TO HELP BIBI,
TRUMP IS TRYING TO HELP BIBI
AND WITHOUT ANY EVIDENCE
WHATSOEVER AND I'M THINKING IF
THERE IS ONE GUY THAT HAS HAD
MORAL CLARITY AND BEEN A
CHURCHILLIAN FIGURE IT IS PRIME
MINISTER NETANYAHU ON GOALIAN
AND JERUSALEM.
>> MAYBE THERE IS A CONSISTENCY.
THE PRESIDENT HELPED ISRAEL
TWICE WITH THE EMBASSY AND THEN
WITH GOLAN.
MANY OTHER THINGS.
PRESIDENT HAD TO REVERSE THE
BETRAYAL OF ISRAEL BY OBAMA.
SO THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN A
GREAT PRESIDENT FOR ISRAEL.
THEN ALSO HE COMES AFTER OBAMA,
THE WORST PRESIDENT FOR ISRAEL.
THE BEST RELATIONSHIP WE'VE
EVER HAD.
IN HELPING ISRAEL HE HELPS THE
PRIME MINISTER.
BUT WHAT ARE YOU SUPPOSED TO
DO, NOT HELP ISRAEL?
>> Sean: THIS HAS BEEN THE BEST
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN JERUSALEM,
NOW BEING THE RECOGNIZED
CAPITAL.
GOLAN HEIGHTS FOR PROTECTION.
I HOPE THE PEOPLE OF ISRAEL
UNDERSTAND.
THEY HAVE ALSO DEVELOPED A GOOD
ALLIANCE WITH THE ARAB